[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welches
heute gibt's eine richtig tolle torte
diese torte werde ich aber nicht alleine
packen heute nämlich ein richtig
besonderer tag den tom kennt ihr das ist
unser kameramann der tom hat ein freund
den fritz komma kurz reinigung und zwar
haben die beiden das sind freunde und
die beiden haben ermöglicht das heute
bei mir eine olympiasiegerin zu gast ist
also ich bin schon ziemlich aufgeregt
und zwar waren ja vor kurzem die
olympischen winterspiele in südkorea
und heute kommt die olympiasiegerin aus
dem deutschen team hier herz gut ich
muss zugeben der sport verbindet uns
vielleicht nicht aber warum trotzdem die
gemeinsame leidenschaft
wir gucken uns mal ein video an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wahnsinn da wenn man richtig schön
können sie mir herzlichen glückwunsch
auch von uns danke schön schön dass sie
heute hier wird ich hoffe die
überraschung ist geglückt
ich freue mich riesig dass ich mal sagen
und eine küche stehen das ja ich habe
mir vorgestellt hast gebracht
ja es wirkt immer ganz anders auf den
videos und das mir helfen bürgern wäre
ich ganz stark alicia schill jung was
mitgebracht war 1000 danke gerster kommt
näher
dankeschön richtig schön ja jetzt ist
olympia knapp über einen monat her
genommen und du hast gewonnen wie fühlt
sich das an
ja es ist der wahnsinn sein gehört zu
den besten sportlern weltweit genau
dritten platz durch gemacht du hast mit
habe ich mitgebracht das sie gemeinsam
war
und ja es ist ein unglaubliches gefühl
da muss man hier natürlich die sie zum
sport sind sehr schwer was wollen die
ist schwer über ein halbes kilo wahnsinn
richtig schön richtig
ja das ist ramona hofmeister unsere
sportlerinnen bei olympia aus dem zürich
sports team und sie sind heute bei mir
in der küche gebacken gemeinsam
ich glaube das ist auch das was uns
verbindet gemacht gehört du wachst gerne
ich mag auch gern sport ist nicht so
mein fall aber vielleicht schaffen wir
sagt dass ich am ende des videos oder am
ende des parkes auch ein bisschen mehr
begeisterung für den sport
vielleicht kann es gäbe dann würde ich
sagen
die steuerzahler klar ich hab dir kurz
und dann kann man vielleicht im
unterhalten
[Musik]
wir haben eine echte profi sportler an
olympischen spielen gewonnen
in südkorea ist wichtig ist dass ganz
wertvolles maximum hänge ich weiß jetzt
auch schon begeisterte sportlerin sie
machen palent bei dir als kind auch
schon so dass er dann wusste ich möchte
mal zu olympia ich möchte mal sportlerin
werden ich möchte gewinnen oder kam es
später irgendwie genau das kam dann mit
der zeit also ich hab zwei ältere
schwestern und die sonst nur über
gefahren und dann wollte ich auch mit
viereinhalb von anfang an sind seitdem
dabei geblieben
aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass dafür
sehr gut trainieren muss ja das stimmt
also freizeit nicht viel
okay aber ich würde sagen wir starten
jetzt auch direkt mit dem backen der
eigentlich lehrer du kannst unser später
helfen wie eine dame zu machen und zu
modellieren
ja ich hole ich dann später dazu wenn
man so weit sind wir bereiten jetzt
schon mal alles vor wir können jetzt mal
die zutaten richtet und deckenhöhe
treffen genau und da können wir starten
für den rührteig nehmen wir 350 kommt
super etwas salz und vanille extrakt
jeweils 150 milliliter buttermilch und
sonnenblumenöl 225 gramm mehl 100 gramm
gemahlene mandeln und ein und halb
teelöffel backpulver er ist im prinzip
ganz einfach ruhe und eben jetzt einfach
die eier wenn du magst kannst du dir
einschlagen und ich nehme immer auch
gerne
das praktische neben dem snowboarden
deine große leidenschaft fürs backen
entdeckt genau also ich glaube eher das
kommt über die familie zwar kein echtes
wort ich gebe dem strich hat der rat
reingeschmuggelt haha ja ich nehme dann
immer noch gerne ein bisschen man immer
extrakten und jetzt kann man im prinzip
den teig schon rührend also die zutaten
verrühren bisschen schön cremig und
schaue mich sind
[Musik]
du magst kannst du ja alles unterheben
und ich gebe dir die zutaten mit 37
alles vor richtig verrührt werden
du kannst du dir vielleicht noch
verraten wie kannst du denn eigentlich
zum backen genau über die familie dass
mein opa war schon becker und mein onkel
hat dann die bäckerei übernommen und da
ist auch eine konditorei drin gewesen
und da habe ich schon sehr viel freizeit
verbrachte meiner kindheit meine ferien
oder so mal reingeschnuppert also schon
richtig in die wege gelegt wird gegangen
ist ein krasser zu sportlerin wurde das
was ich konditorin hast du dann das
backen wahrscheinlich so zum ausgleich
ja das ist auf jeden fall also jetzt oft
dass ich eben vom lehrgang heimkommen
und dann erst mal die koffer in die ecke
stellen und dann wirst du meine ruhe
braucht dann gehe ich erst möglich und
das ist das wirklich so zur entspannung
und zum ausgleich sehr schön
ich werde auch oft gefragt hätte was
machst du in deiner freizeit und ich
muss dann echt auch einmal sagen ich
sage also auch wenn wir in urlaub muss
immer irgendwo in den hotels verpflegung
habe damit den backofen haben oft habe
ich dann in meinen back haben und somit
am 1
ich habe mir die aktuelle runde gepackt
den teig kann jetzt übrigens beliebig
vereinen also man könnte jetzt auch noch
zitronenschale dazugeben oder wer möchte
kann liegt in unserer natur gehen
da ist wirklich super individualisierbar
wenn du alles berührt das können wir
denn hier rein ich habe jetzt einen bug
haben schon mal auf 30 cm eingestellten
das später auch zwei snowboards drauf
passen
ich denke das passt ja und dann bereiten
wir diesen tag einfach noch mal zu
da sind macht es oft genug her hast du
dir austoben
ja und dann bereiten mit dieser position
noch also damit wir auch nicht schöne
hohe treppe hinbekommen
unsere böden sind gebacken und
vollständig abgekühlt jetzt fehlen mir
die worte
ich habe mir gedacht du magst bestimmt
eine fruchtige torte genau und ich habe
schon ein paar frucht einlagen
vorbereitet da könnt ihr schon nach dem
grundrezept schauen
die sind nämlich schon im gefrierfach
und jetzt machen wir eine richtig tolle
creme das somit was capone und sahne das
sage ich mal die zeit haben für die
creme verwenden wir 500 gramm mascarpone
500 gramm sahne 200 gramm schmand oder
joghurt etwas zitronensaft 150 gramm
puderzucker diesen triumph in seiner
fahrt und natürlich vanille
praktikumsbetrieb schon die massen bohne
in die schüssel reingeben genau ein
ich mache den sport dazu und dann kommt
die sahne ganz langsam dazu und wir für
alles und dann bist du nur noch alles
andere dazu geben und die creme schlagen
braucht einen langen sind immer total
genial weil man die früchte püriert und
einfriert und einfach hier einkauft und
dann hat man keine masken früchte in der
torte wachstum da kannst du hören und
ich kann alles andere zu geben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber jetzt fertig und jetzt können wir
die tortenböden einfach so raus lösen
es geht nimmt orten formen messer immer
ganz gut
[Musik]
gibt man trägt es runter zu bekommen und
zwar gibt es das einmal drunter und kann
sein dass barth papier also die folie so
bis in umschlagen und so wegziehen wenn
du privat was machst du dann also ihr
eher selten hörte er dass manchmal
geburtstag ein bisschen genauer ab und
zu mal so eine geburtstagstorte wenn es
um touren geht aber sonst eher so kleine
sachen zu die muffins oder sowas
oder man es braucht er jetzt mache ich
gern letzten den koffer gepackt gepackt
haben und ja da habe ich dann die kurzen
überblick verloren und dann eine pause
eingelegt und wollte mal kurz das packen
und dann habe ich eine schokotart mit
himbeeren obendrauf während den kopf
genau jetzt kann man im prinzip die
torte
dann nehmen wir jetzt die creme und wir
machen ja eine torte
das heißt die wird ein bisschen hoch die
teile welche schoko tat was hat dann
damit gemacht mitgenommen oder milch zu
hause gelaufen zu hause gelassen
nicht erst das gar nicht so gern was
jetzt an gerne verschenkt ist
wahrscheinlich ernst du dich sehr gesund
ja also ich esse ich kein kuchen oder
sowas weil es ungesund ist sondern
einfach weil es damals hieß es
einfach nicht so gerne mal ja hier liegt
er die zubereitung aufgenommen
aber so lässt sich schon auf die
ernährung
ich werde auch oft gefragt und wie sieht
denn alle ich backe für alle werden
morath kennt weiß dass bei murat die
ganze torte essen war er hat auch in den
letzten zehn jahren seitdem wir zusammen
sind 30 kilo zugenommen
ich behaupte ich bin nicht schuld ist
der waschung und ja ja die zweifachen
auch der minister will auch ständig nach
der schule immer mit mir button
das ist auch ihre große leidenschaft
wenn wir gleich die dekoration machen
okay also zuvor schon jetzt kommt da die
frucht einlage drauf und ich machten
auch nicht so sehr wenn sie das süße und
deswegen habe ich hier einfach nur die
früchte püriert und ohne zucker also die
sind jetzt praktisch mit der natürlichen
süße
[Musik]
innen machen weil die mascarpone creme
mit dieser erdbeere waldfrucht einlage
und außen damit was später den schnee
song dessen darstellen können haben wir
ein marshmallow mache mir wirklich
wichtige sinn dass der torte aber
wahrscheinlich einen relaxten wo nimmst
du dich deinen ganzen ganzen inspiration
im heer und die ganze idee hatte praxis
so viele verschiedene torten der hatte
manchmal ich hab's doch ganz normal
manchmal stehe ich auf und denkt so okay
ich hab ich gar keine idee aber dann ist
setzt sich im auto oder im flugzeug
ich war neulich mit dem rad unterwegs
sind und ich wusste ja dass du kommst
als konter überraschen wusste ja und
habe mir dann überlegt okay was könnte
ich mit der ramona zusammenpacken und
habe dann einfach einen zettel
rausgeholt und ipad und dann male ich da
ein bisschen ratlos und war mir das
überlegt mir das thema das ding
geschmack und dann irgendwie weiß nicht
wann kommt immer im kopf irgendwie alles
zusammen und dann entsteht soll die
torte ja also kann man sich das so
vorstellen dass du schon so ein kleines
notizbuch hast wohl aber verschiedene
dort gerne eingezahlt genau und ständig
ich habe immer das handy bei mir und
ständig mache ich mir irgendwo notizen
und jack einfach mal ideen von meinen
zuschauern auf die haben ja auch immer
ganz tolle ideen und anregungen wünsche
familie hat auch viele coole idee dann
orientiere ich mich oft an dass der bau
als er das normalerweise wahrscheinlich
keine schnee torte im brüder will man
aber jetzt passt thematisch sehr gut
von daher also die lieblingsorte von
hier hast du in deinem kopf in dem sich
ja eigentlich sogar schnee taut und die
burg ist somit der karten bis danach ist
auch mit ihm bei frucht einlagen ab ohne
creme die schmeckt nämlich so leicht und
lecker und beim kuchen der mit scp
marktbreite ein mega schokokuchen
deutschland nur so ein kleines stück
essen aber super lecker schmeckt auch
jedem seinen lieblingskuchen max mal
probieren sanierer
ja ja
für hans schon probiert teams
und nicht zu süß ist also wir stellen
jetzt die torte prüft und dann geht's
schon an die deko dankeschön kulissen
lief und was hast du was für die ramona
gebastelt und jetzt wird die torte ok
macht zum nächsten ich habe mich
manchmal direkt sachen dankeschön
also wir brauchen hier kommen wir
sprühen macht eine medaille
einfach aus der metallic farben
wir können später auf die torte
wir machen ja so eine schnee- und da
kann man bc das braucht man vielleicht
ein paar zu gestalten ein kleines
paradies
die waren alle farbe aber irgendwann
[Musik]
ja und wir machen jetzt das nova und
damit wird die formel können hast du mal
mit von dort gearbeitet
ja einmal aber das willst du süß und ich
glaube ich es nur auf wollen brauchen
sie lassen deswegen müssen wir einfach
von dauer und köthen passte und lassen
das ist farblich neutral und können ja
dann alles schön an waren perfekt
praktisch die hölzernen
[Musik]
auch halten tauscht es nur 5 503
anfangen diese becker stärke und dann
hilft es einfach weiter ist schön
gleichmäßig ausbauen können
du kannst du vielleicht mainz noch
ausrollen und ich kann ihnen derzeit
schon mal eine schablone herstellen
nämlich einfach hier und schneit raum
aus
[Musik]
und es ist ja nicht ganz flach geld ich
glaube so leicht gebogen
da könnt ihr euch zum beispiel einen
teller nehmen
[Musik]
dann können wir selbst im prinzip
trocknen lassen die torte ist im
kühlschrank alles ist vorbereitet
ich glaube man jetzt nicht eine
mittagspause ich kümmere mich ums essen
und dann können wir schon bemalen
[Musik]
ok ramona und jetzt kann man im prinzip
unseres labors einmal wie sie teils aus
mainz komplett schwarz gewonnen
das durchstehe linken fuß vorne und dann
ist hier noch das logo von snort der 2
und davon hier die ganzen sponsoren und
hier ist natürlich okay ich habe
scharfschütze gesehen zürich sport ich
kenne mich jetzt beim sport nicht so gut
aus und er was hat da damit damit den an
sich genau also ich bin einem team neben
mir drinnen und die zürich engagiert
sich eben allgemein sehr viel gestreut
und ist auch partner dort schon mit der
mannschaft genau und die haben eben auch
dieses sports team ins leben gerufen und
wir unterstützen uns da eben in
verschiedenen ansichten und das team
stellt sich aus neun sportlern zusammen
und ich hoffe ich bringe sie ganz neue
sportarten zusammen also zb ist aber
nicht dabei dann leichtathletik
shorttrack biathlon opfern schwimmen
beachvolleyball tennis und turnen war
also komplett gemixt schon darauf
wissenschaftler genau wirken jetzt eher
in den märz gerade erst nach einem
teammeeting und ja das land super und
total interessant sich der austauschen
zu können die es bei denen abläuft und
bei uns was ebenso unterschiedlich ist
und wo eben die sommersportler so ihr
trainingslager haben uns da abläuft wie
es jetzt bei dir ich meine snowboard ist
ein wintersport jetzt mitarbeiter als
auch mal was machst du jetzt im sommer
über genauso ich hatte gar keine pause
bei mir ging es gleich weiter wieder in
die ausbildung
die ausbildung bei der bayerischen
polizei räumt also dass mein letztes
ausbildungsjahr genau da bin ich dann
ende juli fertig und es schon zeit auch
wenn hannover fahren als profi und dann
nebenher noch eine ausbildung machen
genau aber eine absicherung
ich bin echt beeindruckt nächste woche
steht das meiner op ich muss mein
handgelenk operieren lassen genau ich
habe mir das im snowboarden gebrochen
und das ist leider nicht so verhält ich
sollte doch ich wusste das schon vor der
sohn aber hast ja schon länger her genau
aber der herbst das nicht so viel sinn
gemacht bevor reparieren zu lassen weil
ich mich ja immer oben aus dem staat
geld rausziehen und dann verhalten
wieder nicht erklären jetzt eben die
wettkämpfe vorbei und olympia ist vorbei
und wird nächste woche gibt es war alles
gut
die op danke schön dass man schon
einiges dann auch zurückstecken
da dann weit zu kommen können aber
leistungssport wäre aber wir haben jetzt
hier lebensmittel haben dass sein leben
so die farbstifte hier sind welche die
wir mit dem pinsel bemalen können
jetzt können wir im prinzip uns kosmos
bemalen
ja ich mache mein traum wenn ich jetzt
hier so eine komplette farbe drauf mache
mache ich denn da wie so eine
grundierung oder mache ich es genau erst
am besten die feinheiten drauf so wird
das logo und team deutschland und ringe
und dann für den rest außenrum anmalen
[Musik]
dinosaur richtig cool aus also schwarz
weiß gefällt mir sehr unterschiedlich
war er unterschiedlicher sagen meint dem
mädchen machen dass meine mädchen
richtig gut fasst ziemlich viele talente
bis zu sagen ok auf dem snowboard hat
mir normalerweise noch halterungen geld
genau das heißt ein fluss ist immer
vorne und eine hinten ist es dann wie
keine ahnung ich bin rechtshänder jetzt
ist mein rechter fuß vorne oder wie
macht man das gar nicht da kann man
gleich einen kleinen test machen
ok ich dich einfach den rücken zu mir
okay und ich hoffe dass ich jetzt mal
ganz neuer linke fuß das wäre ja ich war
auch mit links vorne und das heißt das
immer so macht man halt einfach so aber
es kommt natürlich brauchen geht es
rechts was genau und das nennt man
rechte vorne stellt professor um das
land gut okay also man hat schon in sich
also ich weiß nicht ob es leute gibt die
beides können okay aber genau ich denke
so ein test auch habe aber was mein auge
zutun okay es war es kennt ihr daher
übrigens auch ausprobieren jetzt nehmt
ihr euch entweder ein blatt papier macht
nur noch rein oder ihr nehmt als die
hände macht so genau ganz weit weg
allein springst du mich praktisch durch
das loch durch an und ihr auch so jetzt
gehst du mit der hand immer weiter ins
gesicht dran immer weiter ins gesicht
aber weiter ins gesicht habt ihr
wahrscheinlich alle seit meinem auge
irgendwo gelandet
und dieses auge ist euer dominant das
auge das heißt da kann es dann zum
beispiel auch also das kann auch folgt
auch ausnutzen wenn man zum beispiel
viel am pc arbeitet und ließ unter pc
sehen die rechts von dir aber links ist
ein dominantes auge dann wird man
schneller müde
also musste dann den büros so
positionieren und die sachen so
einstellen dass eben das dominante
daneben geht aber nur einmal weil dann
konzentriert man sich trauer
das geht echt nur einmal
ja weil dann weiß man es schon und dann
steuert man das irgendwie bewusst ich
bin beim snowboard fertig mache hier
schon mal ein bisschen ordnung du malst
noch in ruhe fertig und ich bereits
schon mal das marshmallows nach vor da
könnte ja auch schon das grundrezept
habe ich vor kurzem gekauft wird und das
wird jetzt richtig lecker ok jetzt im
prinzip die torte entweder so lassen
oder so ein bisschen das kuppelförmige
aussieht vielleicht eine wand gesehen
abholen dann glaube ich werde ein
bisschen geschmeidiger aus da ist der
hauptgrund warum sowas wechseln und
damit kann jetzt die komplette theater
erstmal einstreichen und dann ist das
war für den schnee komplett ohne plan
so wie jetzt am besten werkzeugbau
gebrochen und dann der zweite schiff
[Musik]
super das thema noch ein bisschen weh
darüber streuseln und dann unsere
snowboards
[Musik]
so leben für
mit unvertraute jetzt können wir oben
perfekt
[Musik]
das schneiden überlasst dass diesmal die
sie einfach zur seite
einfach mal reinschauen also habe ich
ein schwieriges vor allem bei großen
torten angespannt in neuss sid ich auch
[Musik]
2 schlitt die schichten der frucht
einmal diese medaille haben wir für
bitte gucken wir mal von diesen
wundervollen tag über die gedanken waren
sehr gerne wir backen dürfte und ich
habe sehr viele tipps und tricks werde
ich mitnehmen von mir
dies ist aber schön was ist original
hast du deine eigenen wahnsinn machen ja
ich fand es auch nicht erst mal die
heben wir auf ok die halten wir in ehren
sehr schön
ja ich habe ein bisschen was über deine
sportart gelernt und konnten bisschen
hinter die kulissen blicken
ich glaube meine zuschauer war es auch
super interessant und vor allem ich hab
echt ein riesen respekt vor dir was du
alles dafür tun muss wir haben
erfolgreich zu sein wirklich super schön
ich nehme auf jeden fall gerne den kurs
an bei der man halt so samira wir geben
uns fahren wird und somit aus
entscheiden wie vielleicht erst in die
torte schmeckt ok uns aber sowas und
probieren normal
damit geben und sehr fruchtig schmeckt
das feuer aus den früchten dann der mann
geboten das ist saftig sagen überhaupt
vielleicht gar nicht habe ich also
deswegen passt ist außer mit dem
marshmallow platz kann man ruhig ein
paar gabriel dazu nehmen
und jetzt auch wirklich sehr viel spaß
gemacht das eine richtig coole torte und
vor allem sehr lecker und falls ihr
diese über man schnee bäume genau auf
nach machen wollt dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei auf treknews.de da steht
noch mal alles ganz genau macht die
torten man könnte unter markieren wenn
ihr noch weitere infos über ramona haben
wollt könnt ihr auch auf instagram
schauen da schaue ich übrigens auch rein
und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten
mal kommt mal alle probieren kann die
com
[Musik]